avant match États-Unis Iran une
rencontre cruciale qui va au-delà du
sport
répression en Iran drapeau palestinien
soutient à la communauté LGBT brimée
la géopolitique et les préoccupations
sociales s'invitent sur le terrain de
foot comme jamais auparavant
si les appuis ou Palestiniens sont
tolérés par l'organisation Cathary bon
nombre de spectateurs découvrent les
restrictions à la liberté d'expression
lors de cette Coupe du monde
américaine Saïd kamalinya a réussi à
entrer avec son chandail femme vie
liberté en appui à la révolte contre le
régime
pour déjouer la sécurité à l'entrée du
stade ça aide et ses amis ont été
arrêtés puis interrogés par les
autorités
qatari pendant 4 heures à leur sortie du
match
soudainement des gardiens de sécurité
s'interposent pendant l'entrevue avec
Saïd malgré les protestations
pour s'éviter des controverses et lécher
son image le Qatar interdit la prise
d'image presque partout sauf sur les
sites de la FIFA les atteintes à la
liberté d'expression ont pris plusieurs
formes des spectateurs ont dû retirer
leur chandail et même leur montre aux
couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel tout ce qui
s'apparentait à du soutien pour la
communauté LGBT était interdit la FIFA
est intervenue la semaine dernière pour
que ces messages d'appui soient
dorénavant toléré un homme avec un
drapeau arc-en-ciel et un message contre
la répression en Iran a d'ailleurs sauté
sur le terrain lundi
ça aide lui a assisté aux Coupe du Monde
précédentes au Brésil et en Russie il
affirme que ces pays avaient fait un
effort pour accueillir les visiteurs
que la panne de discrimination et que
les journalistes étrangers ne rapportent
pas vraiment ce qui se passe avec la
Coupe du Monde il s'est Philippe Leblanc